you
Super blitz arena
so feel free to join me it's a 57 minute
tournament
we're going to do the rest of this one
futures trader
first no not our first time playing
let's all get Jerry somebody says hey
how about
we start with a pawn duo
hello
okay yeah
I guess they're playing d5 I'll take
them out
and open my bishops eyes immediately
kind of castle
you gotta
got a castle
you
no up okay so I don't have to worry
about this kind of pressure
suppose I just react energetically here
energetically
let's do it I want my bishop
my Bishop's presence to be felt in the
only way his presence is felt over here
on the Queen side is to make a break at
d5 say must
probably could have saved some seconds
here you don't feel kind of just kind of
have the bishop staring at upon any
Eddie Rock
so there we go I'm trying to show that
my bishops position is much better than
this guy's
all right
I don't want to give up this Center pond
so we're gonna do this of course they
could take the beep on now but my knight
could probably be a great bother on d6
in the queen let's not forget she might
be short on squares so Queen takes b2
Queen a4 threatens a trap no not quite
it's close Queen here however threatens
a trap
extra tempting
extra tempting
let's try that
Queen trap alert
we have to be one queen I think has to
just bolt
you
on a night move I could probably jump in
here I have this square already in mind
Queen the airy
clean there a
start with this get out of the line of
fire I was tempted to go at this one but
I don't like keeping my rook stuck like
that
Queen a5 Queen e7
are the only options Queeny 7 it is
I could try for this
let's see if I can provoke a weakness
yes I can and now I have this idea it's
definite compensation here
now we slide on in there and there's
gonna be Discovery Zone soon Discovery
Zone we might have some little windmill
action uh-oh oh this is game over this
is a winning move my knight and my
bishop can either directly or indirectly
control all four of these squares
so Queen here here the night drops in
the Queen s to go here here I take here
return take here
return a might just resign
a knight and Bishop windmill normally
it's with the bishop in a rook you know
focusing on a something near the king
like that but a little windmill against
the Queen you don't get to see this
actually I don't think I'm for me ever
done something like this before
to a queen
with an item bishop
first of its kind for me I think
we'll see
a futures trader comes up with it
doesn't look good yeah we'll take the
the bigger prize first
it's pretty interesting
maybe there was a night move there
all right let's let's return there's the
windmill
turn and now I'll go this now there's
this guy here I don't even want that
though
let's go here threatening a check and
then this
so now oh is this a back-to-back
windmill
torture now a back-to-back windmill
action tack
peas play ooh look at this
Caparo t1 or as I used to say Kappa rot
and as you would expect at three
berserk here we go good ol cat
the chess cube days let's throw the
French
I don't want to see this guy
let's try that
I really don't know what I'm doing in
this position
let's develop like that just in case
this file opens up
okay
I'm a just 1/2
place c5 next
it's weakening I'm ready to book over
here though so I might just launch ponds
gain some Tempe whoa can't do that
g5 g42 crazy let's try it
these these moves hit pretty hard
this is a lock center is there a great
way for a white to crack open the
position
if there is I'm not seeing
see five now
just want the Queen other way so I could
go here how'd I pull that off
here doesn't make too much sense
all right let's let's sharpen it up in
the center as well I need a square for
my queen so I key I can't castle here so
yeah oh and there's that move so already
went upon all right we're doing a pawn
sack just give me the file
now maybe I know I just take them out
alright so now we go here down upon but
we have we have lines to attack with
gah files ready Castle queenside they're
going to take this pond out
I could do this
who
might have to give up another pond
start with that should just back up
who
really that's a surprising move
but this was the more I'm way down at
time
do I really have to do something baby
like rooked fa and then castle
well I don't want to have to do that
okay you forced my hand okay if you're
gonna take maybe you're in a pin that's
uncomfortable let's find out
yeah
thing is here
interesting position say the least
this night is so stupid if I can't make
use of these squares what what is even
happening I think I have to reposition
play play where there are some gaps in
my opponents camp knight c6 Knight a5
the c4 square
meanwhile they're going to focus on that
I don't know how much of a bother that
really is to me
now I could actually do this move the
knight shields the Queen's pressure from
f7
how do I make progress though I don't
know that's like a passing move
another another passing okay maybe my
queen
kind of slithers on over
everything sealed over here
Kings Kings ready to go somewhere else
stay ahead on the clock here
let's get this rook here
you
let's go here
you
hmm
you
transfer
I want my bishops eyes to open up
you
okay
you
you
through me
can't take twice there
and now they could take care
how's a blunder on my part
main to threat
you
they're way down on time
on the night
ah
oh I didn't mean to do that
it was very important that I stay
on the clock there
very important that was tough
you could tell by our moves and that
came that
we both reached a point where we just
didn't know what to do we were both
trying to move fast make non-committal
stuff not non-committal moves
yeah
all right Zach
I
a centered counter
any Scandinavian
and against Zack first time playing
against Zack nine one zero zero three
zero
what can that number possibly mean
it seems like one of those
user name suggestions like you just type
in Zack and it says that user name is
already taken try these I don't know
it's not a birthdate is it too many
numbers
no maybe not
anyhow what's going on here nothing it's
a slow physician a question I have is
will c4 be played or not there's there's
my answer
so it's certainly more aggressive
to play with this
this is more conservative and solid
and I'm do I play this straight away I
think that this will be the reply and
Zack is
playing solid
no weaknesses really for either of us
both very good structures
computer would like lights
in this not much better a little bit
better
because of the this structure
no-no-no let's expand now if the night
ever moves a a five is nice a four is
nice
all right now what are you up to let's
let's ask the bishop a question for
starters I'm inviting a sacrifice as
well I should have probably considered
that but I I don't quick to have pieces
over here to defend there's actually all
of my minors are around so now there's
going to be a structural not a
structural change a shift in the
evaluation I'm working with the bishop
pair White has to now be very cautious
about the dark-squared bishop
let's take him out I don't have another
choice and let's just centralize my
Queens here to defend that
blender
nice time edge in fact this is my this
is my idea
I want to
this open
so he's in the pen I want to look to
exploit this Queen here here I imagine
let's do it
you
okay
you
I don't know I first I can't really
explain why I'm doing this move I just
oh okay I don't I don't want to invite
the night so let's say B 5 so easily
but he's gonna get there and you know
III think I have to do this to make
forward progress well here's the other
thing v6 will add some nice supports my
bishop so I could I could maybe think
about Queen g3 at some point this Knight
is still in a pin what's wrong with this
this is winning stuff
yeah
one one pin or the other
calculate for a moment I take your queen
you take my queen
yeah
I take care first
then after this move my queen attack
your knight and attack the Queen the
Queen comes back here what do I have in
that position I don't think anything
ah
all right I'm gonna I'm going to
let's go here
you
let's push I want to make some I want to
try and show that this night is actually
out of play
he's on a good square but now the
actions turning over here
I could control the flight square
let's pair this in mind
you
I wanted to go here dropping some stuff
yo I got to take him out that's going to
be too strong
down on time as well
that's not working
proper peace now
you
you
they started to fly for sure
you
Wow
Wow Zack
Wow
was that a newer account
and the rating hasn't caught up to
planning strength
No
stuff game
it's very lucky that
I was able to pick off the rook there in
that time scramble
no the cap again
the cap is throwing the banana at me
let's run with this you know I forget I
forget the line
that I covered with stockfish versus I
forget what the computers were
here
and then here
try and hang on to that pond
castle
and we're
go from this point
I could do this
could do this as well
let's start with this it's not as
committal
I want to put a rook right here let's
try for that now even if it costs me the
exchange
got about that idea
you
let's take
you
well my nights gonna get a boot - anyhow
don't like how I play these last handful
moves I would like a night right here go
for that
you know
that's too crazy
hmm
wasting so much time
spending so much time
all right the stink oh well I want
bishop
I want something here I referenced a
rook a knight
a bishop I'll take I'll take any piece
into that square
okay got what I wanted
where are the tactics there any around
you
I don't know what I want to do
[Music]
you
I don't know
I'm
it's almost a guarantee that I lose on
and our time with this one yeah
here is that
haha boy
so he's gonna get captured how am i down
upon I started out up upon now I'm down
upon
gotta hang on him
I - hanging it to the seventh ring
and make something
magical happen there let's put pressure
on this prawn I think he's going to fall
maybe queen here
a lot of maybes
shrine hang on him they could do this
and force a queen exchange
go after this guy
you
I'm thinking my I thinking my bishop is
here
you
not sure what I'm doing
what I have been doing for the past many
moves
you
back rank mates
you
going into pens
you
20 seconds oh can I just get this pond
you
yeah
yeah that'll work
oh I really floundered in that opening
not good
she'll stir dude thank you for
subscribing
and I know a black did there was just
not good but I just didn't find a way to
take advantage of that
okay
where we are in the I'm in 25th okay
I'm going to try and push through with
d5
try
they could connect
I'm just going to take
and maybe push through no matter what
you know queen here's suicidal
whoa
can't do that
okay now we got discovered discovered
tricks
you
you
this should be punished
somehow
don't want it I do not want to trade
Queens
you
you
all right let's let's develop like this
all right
okay this is really close to me I'm
going to start with this
then you have something fancy
Cley
what's my fancy idea here here here here
isn't quite May
ha I could take the Queen first
let me just got I'm gonna run it like
that I don't see a goodnight move here
they take like that and have a new
square
didn't get the most out of that one
either
you're not safe I should have played
this instead of the flight square okay
now I have this looking here so it's got
to do weird stuff
let's target f2 down on time this is a
good position
materials balanced their development is
backwards
you
where are the checks
okay now we have multiple ways I want to
keep this night around actually he's
very good at stopping
I could have done this and in this
all right we're gonna go check our way
to winning some more material
Maes this is close to me panic away
just going to take the material now
of two ponds
Bishop here right there right there here
anything just move fast
all right
so we're getting a queen exchange
his pawn
bishop and then land a fork
anything better oh the night could
actually take I didn't go with it
all right I'm up three pawns let's get
the last piece involved let's put the
knight on a secure square
secure every
I had him indirectly defended and now
the king wants to play the knight can't
improve the rook really well I guess he
could go here let's let's put pressure
on this and stop this pawn break no
fancy sacrifices oh there's that move
and this
yes we just offer rook exchange
declined let's flush the night away
you
it's defended
just trying to keep my eyes open for the
crazy forks
how's he getting stopped
where's the mate
there it is back to Herman
oh okay
yeah someone's Jesse hf2 is saying in
the chat Knight takes g3 check yeah I
thought they would take with the f-bomb
the king could kind of slip out
and DMS is saying a Dutch how about we
do a reverse Dutch the birds opening ah
what do they call this
from from gambit I'm not accepting that
this is just a simple way to approach
the e 5 D 6 thing
all right let's ask him a question
I'll take at this point
and okay we just know I'll go here I
don't want the Queen to sweep in
they just want me to take this pawn
maybe I will yeah
I'll take it now I have enough
development in here queenside castle I
could go in either direction I prefer to
go queenside in this position just so it
doesn't enter race position
so I actually I could take you it's
check I just put the bishop here bishop
check here doesn't scare me castle by
hand
that move
all right let's keep the Queen in in
blacks house
once more this doesn't scare me the
night is under control I have a good
harmony here
between struck
Bishop notes sacrifices even though I'm
in a pin this is secure
by my night I can test the F file I'm
leaning more towards this than this so I
could run away here
ready to take my night out but they
missed that my queen is on the bishop
okay
and now we
for trades
in May threats possibly
no no fear no fear of this King is just
gonna book
well let's sneak in for starters and
then we could kind of put the brakes on
let's let's just just to address these
threats I just want to be assured my
queen sneaks in here
let's go with that
eventually they're gonna be scared of
this move now we centralize night here
we run away and everything is is cool
here is if I could control d7
okay now the nice ready to block but we
could take advantage of that pin
um oh maybe we can't take advantage of
that pin
alright let's just let's just get out of
harm's way
take stuff
I am up at night and a couple ponds
couple a couple to two or three
now there's just no counter play
for trades
and improve the King
you
already
push the ape on
a-five a-six a-seven
you know to promote
you
right here
you
back determine
here they were trying to stir up
something in the opening
[Music]
I see the idea I just I don't think it
was really there
you know I was slightly behind in
development so my opponent was trying
you know crack open the physician
you don't think there's just I don't
think there's enough compensation
who
you
let's do something different
queen d3
I don't know I don't know what the exact
point of this is but we'll try to
inject some
weird imbalance into the position I
think this is an opportunity for it
ship back have a little space now
or movies by considering that I wonder
we're gonna go with this and then this
and then I want to make sure he stays
around
now let's put a piece on him
I've neglected kingside development so
far
that's an idea isn't it
you
I'm gonna go with this I want to keep
this square can under control
so I have an e file to work with at some
point this might actually be a serious
threat in fact I mean what it what is
black actually doing in reply to Knight
b5 I also open up a Queen move here
threatening to get on this dog and will
be for the bishop I'm also fighting for
this this d4 square
so clean here
I feel like this is a good move I'm
prepared to take with the pawn doubled
pawns in this case I like
I get I can use a pawn around closer to
the center to control some dark squares
I am apps in a dark square Bishop this
is now a threat the King has to go here
I imagine one of those two moves
my Nike get flushed away soon it's
probably just going to happen do i
queenside castle or play rook to d1
hmm
it's actually it's ooh
oh really so you're going to
counterpunch here
check here here and then the rook moves
my night might get trapped
I'm going to say queenside castle I am
threatening that
you
I guess we'll go to a light square I
think he's a long way off from bothering
me I'll jump in here I'm gonna try to
make something happen with this night
though I mean he's let's secure this I
don't want black to pry open the the
queenside
too easily I'm trying to play against
this bishop if Ike if I can stop the
bishop from developing I'm kind of
stopping the rook as well so they're
investing some material in order to do
what exactly
taking with the c-pawn because i think i
just want to recapture with the piece
develop
this certainly has its points as well
though
I'm going to say it's more important to
develop
Knight f3
I could anchor in him in here if the
night does this I don't like giving up
these squares but this is something
possibly
also short on time under forty twelve
minutes to go in the tournament
Sall good thank you for subscribing
has alpha0 changed the way I play
I feel it's had some influence on my
play actually
want to jump on in you know looking for
these little ways to kind of limit a
particular piece certainly has me
thinking more about the game it has me
thinking more about different strategies
alright he's now passed let's just find
a safe Square for the bishop this is
this is safe
and he's ready to be challenged
you
hmm
you
can't take
you
look at look at sacrifices on this
square at some point bishops ready to
get crunched
no time all day resigned you know I was
tough to play towards the end there
as her own thank you for subscribing
and calles 3 thank you for the 10 months
in a row man
many thanks calles 3
you
what's up Jones triple sevens
ten minutes to go
other logic
is the opponent
first time playing other logic
let's try Dutch
I will go with the fiend keto
t6 let's try for this
okay
you
alright I'm gonna go with let's go it's
c6 I like having this square open
thank you very much CJ
500 bits
you add these games have been very
instructive I'm glad to hear that a
little bit of fun and education
okay we are just going to babysit for a
little bit babysit for a little bit at
some point the bishop can get shut out
of the game
very quickly I think now is the time for
it
be a little bit careful here threatens
Queen here can't rush in for efore right
away but we could always develop a hair
just a hair and if they do this c4 is
extra sensitive okay we're gonna go for
this pawn sacrifice this is an extremely
valuable pawn this is the heart of
whites King side structure so
he's now no longer these guys are split
and now there are four holes on the
Kings side and this bishop is tactically
vulnerable in fact at this point I
thought I could go here but then there's
this but what I do have is this here in
defense
careful this might be a move
take stakes no excuse me my rook is
protected
okay my night here is not protected so
this could be an issue at some point
okay they could be winning this phone
they are going to be winning this pawn I
do have the bishop hair though things
have opened up I don't know how great a
piece this guy is uncie - we both have
to keep our eyes open
I would rather keep the Queen's on I
don't know if I could really avoid the
Queen exchange though
screen has a lot of pressure on my
position I think I need to get the move
back
hang on
I have a tactic it takes night
just took out the legs
they all sweep
and then recapture him up peace
Pras mister
here
here here takes takes
it simplifies a bit more giving up upon
I'd get the b2 pond though
okay let's start with this move actually
no no no I'm going to take care
and then make sure I take the heart so
now these are guys are all very weak
now we stand a dark Square
yeah and now without the b-pawn around
this will be a wonderful square I can
find really good squares on
on the dark color
44 seconds
might just be winning this pawn
rook here I secure the night
and now now these guys are
superglued into the dark squares stay
here
where's another good home on the dark
square right here
for threat
here and there's the fork
the only reason
okay only five minutes to go got 20
maybe we get to the front this would
actually scoop me right on up there to
number five with the win
just goes to show how close a pack this
is
all right see POC
oh it's different
I'm gonna try this again
alright let's just get the miners out
and I want to take
let's go with h6
let's connect Knights
supporting in five I just want I want to
stay out of my off pants where
you
let's jump right in for this
I did this I don't know some capture and
then a push or here forcing my hand and
then some action in the centers kind of
scared me take with the bishop
here's tempting as well fighting for
this square forcing probably Bishop
takes bishop
but on the other hand I do want to
develop
I like having a square for my queen No
ruled out yeah I have ruled out castling
queenside let's just go Kings side get
two good things King safety rook
activity and I'm satisfied with that
okay that seems like it's a passing move
what exactly is that doing let's start
with this now that the dark square
bishop tsar not around f4 becomes super
serious and let's might as well develop
and make why think about these potential
sacrifices
and this night just gave up that square
lets happen
this ties down the queen puts pressure
on the bishop my pieces are swarming in
soon all of them can be playing
whereas I don't know how the rooks play
for white
you know where's the pawn break I could
win upon but I feel like I should be
going for more here
like take here there should be something
juicy
something really juicy should be here
starts with this and just kind of I'm
trying to say that the night is out of
play he's not around to help defend
against
all these pieces that are inching in
like Queen here I believe I could take
and then take here and then the Queen's
in trouble yeah
case in point and there's no in-between
there I have this covered
so I mean three pieces were on this so
each three was red-hot
Blaine here could probably do that slip
on in threatened meydani too
I'm even I think these three pieces
alone might be enough to generate some
mating attack I always have a rook that
I could sacrifice to knock out a
defender the knight in the pawn on g2
are the main defenders here and that's a
fork
now we're just in the the mopping up
phase
we've gathered some material
here and then sneak in they mouth
slipped you know I think that's a
tournament pairings closed
eighth place at the moment this could
definitely change but I am NOT I am NOT
going to get any more games in
good games off in early good games off
all right and thank you very much to
kelas three
for the $50 donation
you are a donating machine you've
donated before I believe not in this
stream but thank you very much
Kellis three
seconds hand Fineman Dirac thank you
very much man
I also missed a couple other subs
while I was playing
we'll see that the final standings are
here 20 seconds before the top three get
some confetti
Fineman Dirac thank you for the tier one
sub many thanks man
why did I miss from earlier okay first
let's see this here alright final
standings
Don took first
go pet oh two two two
and this guy top-3 216
let's see all the pages
h 2 4 5 ok I'm not gonna count them all
let's just see everybody that was
competing John wick
we've played many over 20
Coolio I see many new names
yeah well a lot just with a couple games
and then they they took a hike all right
that's everything in good games all
you